[Musique]
c'est peut-être possible, nous avons tous
vu ce film, nous savons comment il se termine,
pensez-vous que les talibans respecteront tout
accord,
nous sommes si proches de l'oubli
[Musique]
alors ils le porteront à Kaboul pendant une semaine ou
deux quand c'est vrai  si vous êtes à la recherche de l'
Atlantide, oh oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] le
capitalisme, la pièce devrait avancer avant
dix mille plus dangereux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons récupéré une interception qui vient
des talibans, nous avons un accord, alors nous avons
un  affaire, vous avez un traître dans votre camp,
avez-vous déjà conspiré avec un
officier des renseignements étrangers,
je ne le savais pas, comment pouvez-vous en être si sûr s'il
y a 180 jours de votre vie, vous ne vous souvenez pas
où étiez-vous qui portez, j'ai perdu sept
mois de ma vie.  dites-moi que je n'ai aucune
chance de vous venger, de sortir de notre pays,
laissez-nous tranquilles,
vous êtes hors réseau pendant plus de 90
minutes, suffisamment de temps pour appeler
mon gestionnaire russe pour lui dire
exactement ce qu'il veut entendre
[  Musique]
Je crois que personne d'autre ne le fera
[Musique]
vous
c'est peut-être possible, nous avons tous
vu ce film, nous savons comment il se termine,
pensez-vous que cela tiendra même un
accord, nous sommes si proches de l'oubli
[Musique]
et ils portent à Kaboul pendant une semaine ou
deux quand tout de suite, si vous êtes prêt, les
lettres sont oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Coble n'est pas la pièce qui devrait bouger avant qu'elle ne
soit dix mille plus dangereuse [
Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
nous avons capté une interception qui était en avance
sur les talibans nous avons un accord alors nous
avons un accord
nous avons un traître dans votre camp avez-vous
déjà conspiré avec un
officier du renseignement étranger je ne savais pas comment pouvez-
vous en être si sûr s'il y a 180 jours  de
ta vie, tu ne te souviens pas
où étais-tu, ce porteur, j'ai perdu sept
mois de ma vie, dis-moi que je n'ai pas de
chance, prends Delta pour un
pays, laisse-nous tranquilles, tu es hors
réseau pendant plus de 90 minutes.  assez
de temps pour téléphoner à mon
maître russe pour lui dire exactement ce qu'il
veut entendre, je crois que personne
d'autre ne le fera.
[Musique]